TO THE POSSIBILITY LAST WEEK.
LAURA.
>> Laura: JENNIFER, THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
JOINING ME NOW IS CHRISTIAN
MacLEOD, THE WIFE OF ONE OF
THE CONTRACTORS WE JUST HEARD
ABOUT, HE WAS CONVICTED FOR
KILLING UNARMED CITIZENS
RESPONDED TO THAT CAR BOMB
ATTACK IN 2007 AND IS IN A U.S.
FEDERAL PRISON AS WE SPEAK.
PROSECUTORS IN THE MEDIA SAY
THIS IS A CLEAR-CUT CASE OF
AMERICAN CONTRACTORS STEPPING
OVER THE LINE THAT THEY ARE
STILL SUBJECT TO U.S. LAW AND
LAW IN FOREIGN COUNTRIES MAY
HAVE TO SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES
>> BY CITY LAW HAS TO APPLY TO
EVERYBODY BUT WHAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
HERE IS THE LAW.
THIS INVESTIGATION WAS PERFORMED
BY A COLONEL WHO WAS TIED TO
TERRORIST ALLEGATIONS OF THE FBI
DIDN'T TURN UP THREE WEEKS
LATER.
THEY ACCEPTED THIS AS PRESENTED
TO A JURY OF WASHINGTON, D.C.,
SEVEN YEARS LATER.
THEY PUT LIPSTICK ON A PIG AND
PRESENTED IT AS A FACT AND THAT
IS A PROBLEM FOR ELSE.
THE CASE WAS DISMISSED AFTER THE
FIRST THREE YEARS FOR RECKLESS
VIOLATIONS AND ONLY CAME BACK
AFTER PARTICLE PRESSURE FROM THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> Laura: YOU HURTS MILITARY
LEADERS SAYING, THIS WOULD BE
EIGHT TERRIBLE PRESIDENT FOR
THEM TO DO THIS.
WHAT YOU SAY?
>> I DON'T THINK HE SHOULD
CREATE BOTH SELF PARDON PROCESS
IS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE ACCUSED OF
CRIMES BECAUSE THEY ARE
SERVICE MEMBERS BUT I DO THINK
HE HAS NOT ONLY THE RIGHT BUT
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO LOOK AT
THINGS LIKE THAT WHEN WE HAVE
SEEN SO MUCH PRESIDENT OF THE
PRAYER MINISTRATIONS WITH THE
AND FBI
HITCH UP AGAINST THEIR ENEMIES
WERE PEOPLE THAT SERVED THEIR
POLITICAL AGENDA.
>> Laura: YOUR HUSBAND HAD AN
INCREDIBLE MILITARY CAREER, GOOD
CONDUCT METALS, ELECTIVE SERVICE
RIBBONS, AIR FORCE RESERVE
METALS, COMBAT INFANTRY.
PRETTY INCREDIBLE CAREER.
THEY THOUGHT WOULD BE HE JUST
SNAPPED?
>> THAT IS THE MOST RIDICULOUS
THING.
IF YOU WANT ONE PERSON EVERY DAY
OF YOUR LIFE, I TOTALLY PERSON
ONE DAY.
THE MOST SERIOUS VIOLATION IS A
TRAFFIC VIOLATION.
HE HAS BEEN IN PRISON FOR FOUR
YEARS AND HE HAS USED THAT
ATTEMPT TO BETTER HIMSELF AND TO
LEAD PEOPLE.
HE HAS A PURPOSE AND HE BELIEVES
HE HAS A PURPOSE IN BEING IN THE
PLACE HE HAS NOW BUT WE WANT
THAT TO BE OVER.
WE WANT GOD TO RESTORE HIM TO
OUR FAMILY.
MY HUSBAND USES THESE LITTLE
ORIGAMI BOOKS TO MAKE LITTLE
ANIMALS OUT OF DOLLAR BILLS FOR
MY DAUGHTER WHEN WE VISIT HIM.
WE BELIEVE IN GOD AND WE BELIEVE
THERE IS A PURPOSE AND WE
BELIEVE HE DOES ALL THINGS FOR
GOD.
>> Laura: YOU BELIEVE IN YOUR
HEART HE DID NOT FIRE ON UNARMED
CIVILIANS?
>> MY 15 YEAR ANNIVERSARY WITH
THIS MAN IS TOMORROW THAT I CAN
TELL WITH EVERY AMOUNT OF
CONFIDENCE FROM DAY ONE THAT HE
DID NOT HURT PEOPLE
INTENTIONALLY.
THEY WERE NOT A THREAT TO HIM.
>> Laura: THEY WERE TAKING
INCOMING FIRE AND HAD TO RESPON
RESPOND?
THE FBI DIDN'T SHOW UP FOR THREE
WEEKS?
THAT'S KIND OF AN
ANTI-BLACKWATER DEAL, THERE WAS
A BIG PUSH AGAINST BLACKWATER
AND THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
I WAS THERE FOR A WEEK AND I WAS
HEARING BLACKWATER AND I WAS
LIKE --
THERE WAS A LOT OF
ANTI-BLACKWATER SENTIMENT.
>> ABSOLUTELY IS WITH A CRAZY
THING ABOUT THIS, I HAD       MY
THING ABOUT THIS, I HAD       MH
THING ABOUT THIS, I HAD       MS
THING ABOUT THIS, I HAD       MA
THING ABOUT THIS, I HAD       MD
GETS BACK AND HE SAID IT WAS
LIKE A NORMAL DAY AT THE OFFICE
BUT IT WASN'T, THE RESPONSE TO
IT.
>> Laura: LETS PEOPLE ARE
KILLED, WHAT DO YOU MEAN NORMAL
DAY AT THE OFFICE?
>> UNFORTUNATELY THAT WAS IN
BAGHDAD.
>> Laura: BUTTIGIEG JUST